whoa but since you're standing there's
going to be more traversing of the
sagittal plane it's going to be more
inertia get it when we went up with more
forces so what's going to happen is you
you cannot have these kind of
conclusions okay
you can't use the shortening of this to
do what you want to do so you have your
Kentucky Derby hat and strangely this is
the same shape as your okay okay so my
hands are more like that you see because
that gives me structural integrity
that this is difficult more difficult to
do so if boom whoa I move my body to get
everything and to make that absorb the
energy that you're trying to absorb with
your hands or in your arms again so
we're here boom shape
[Music]
so start close right in here okay
look how or at this point because of his
additional intention his plant is on
this side of where that punch is going
if you pay attention okay he's he's
bought a lot of weight there you see
that the square of intensity of good
balance do you see the difference so I'm
using him
this pattern of him going around to
generate the tilt that I want you see
because I need to get that tilt that we
always get and then I come in and I send
the bottom half on the X pattern out we
are not going whoa ha I'm not doing that
he's already Tildy Tildy Tildy still TDC
beside whoa that circles doing it head
is now slightly to the right of the spot
[Music]
the heel doesn't whoa right here
I haven't waited but he's already
disorganized and then I move it and it
hits the tilt I walk so the dude is
already barley and now I just come in
and deconstruct the base his body is on
the forward progress around
[Music]
okay